recipes recipes pessaries recipes
recipes recipe what how did I end up
here
ah [ __ ] naughty [ __ ] again alright Prez
we're back in stranded dip so uh lost my
say funny story you saw it in the last
episode you know what let's find Shannon
let's find some sharks and it's get the
[ __ ] outta here hey mr. crab man are you
doing I'm not even gonna say anything oh
I'm sorry dr. crab Jesus Christ boots a
[ __ ] stupid can you be
it's been five episodes hey man I'm
sorry man Jesus oh it's this missus crap
oh that's so good don't go near are you
son of a [ __ ] sweetie we we Gemma
barely meets his crap don't listen to
him Marguerite shut up you son of a
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] Cali a parrot
dude dude don't worry she's fine she's
fine Oh mommy a big sit here you piece
of [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate your pants some
men just want to watch the world burn
alright well let's grab dr. crab now
piss I need to be with my wife no you
can't do this pills you shaking [ __ ]
sit down we gotta go an adventure dr.
crab crab calling dr. crab dr. crab dr.
crab get up now get up now dr. crab what
are you doing whoa
oh my god I can push dr. crab look out
faith keep doing it dr. crab
I got Darla it's dr. crab this is genius
oh my god who needs a motorboat when you
can push dr. kramm alright perch I'll
use my superpowers yes
look out [ __ ] fast we are wait dr.
crab
dr. Crabbe dr. Bob where do you go have
you son of a [ __ ] I need you I need you
in my life for you to stay no no no no
no don't go word what the [ __ ] is hey
dr. crab you [ __ ]
well let's do it with the the coconut
then god damn it
oh yeah well see I'm faster than sharks
now all about the put a pie express yeah
I don't know we're we're sick ah no no I
almost died it's um is it up site it's
[ __ ] upside down over it and you are
alright well [ __ ] it duct tape woo
everyone is out there making duct tape
we did it to danger Shannon's calling
you let a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do though you know what I'm gonna
360 noscope your bench
ha ha that's rock ok go to see kick it a
shake come back come back yeah that's
right fight me fight me like a man
Shannon even though you're a woman oh
yeah that's right
you scared OH get leaked you freaking a
big high putz
yeah yeah doing buddy we're best friends
beards we're best friends
oh my god oh my god no no for the love
of God Shannon for the love of what just
happened all right oh all right aah
shouting stop it's my teleportation
powers I'm sorry I didn't you change man
Beckett you back back in the day you
used to play amnesia ah goddamn it stop
making me tell it
oh god oh god oh god I'm so dead stop
making me flying stop stop bed shed oh
god damn it
Shannon became a shark aah I'm so sad
we're gonna cook some shiny tonight oh
yeah we're gonna cook some shiny tonight
like I'll paddle on that long girl
Shannon is my friend and I will eat her
chili and we're stuck the crab I know
you're here you sly son of a [ __ ] hey
my buddy dr. Craig Oh
Lane she said my name right hey let's
let's have a little party I invited you
let's play some music what would you
like to hear um do you have some jazz
yeah you know what that's um jazz no I
don't have it actually [ __ ] yeah
that's right dance crab that's right go
do crab yay yay break it down now
oh hey where the [ __ ] are you going
hurts head [ __ ] heart what's that I
can't hear you oh this party ever dr.
crab oh look Shannon's dancing - hey
look Shannon's dancing hey what a great
party
hey you're looking at ha oh you're
looking out you set of a tree that's
right you know [ __ ] with me [ __ ] you're
my hero
shut up Jennifer I mean of course I am
if only Shannon was here I guess her
ghost is here dance dance dance dance
dance dance dance dance dance dance
dance dance thanks
ah moaning comes what a night what a
night indeed um all right well Heather
hey but I love you shut your mouth
Heather I think I forgot about you and
your misdeeds okay Heather you're too
fat for the boat no look I totally fit
all right yeah you know you know what
whatever you say many hell is this oh my
god this is dr. crab Amy
there's please no we're immigrating to
another Island for better times Oh
how the [ __ ] am I gonna make a motorboat
in this game if I can't motorboat a
cramp so ever we have a propeller and we
have a duct-tape what else do we need
tank don't have carburetor don't know
what that is engine don't have that fuel
tank okay next goal
a bucket there a carburetor
we need that what we got at work I don't
need a [ __ ] torch oh this could be
good
flippers flippy floppies ah bucket yeah
I need a bucket idiot give me something
ah [ __ ] bucket oh my god need an
engine Oh two engines hmm oh my god oh
my god oh we have the tank we had the
carburetor if we had the propeller we
had the duct tape no no I am in French
baguette right now I'm so excited and I
just can't hide it all right engine
carburetor hater duct tape gas tank
propeller but a bing bada boom bada BAM
bada boom bada boom bada BAM yep that's
the foundation right here oh there it is
okay okay you brush already took so long
so very very long while wearing a thong
girl oh oh come on dr. Craig where are
you little [ __ ] I need you hypose I was
not trying to hide from you all right
want to see something amazing dr. crab
I'm not gonna see your penis for the
last time no not that all right sit down
what what the [ __ ]
a crab what are you doing hey I'm just
driving the boat look at me yeah I'm
putting pie with you funny noises big
duck crab what are you doing stop all
right start it there we go it's working
are we staring at Hey survival survival
force we turn no let's go into circles
crab calling dr. crab
see you later dr. crab I'm going how
mama riding off to the sunset there's no
sunset but let's pretend there is
amazing amazing they thought I couldn't
survive while
build an engine alright press again I've
done episode or they have you know it's
an probably watching if you leave a like
if you did and now but every day how
many but everywhere them